how's it going everybody it's Warren and
this past weekend at cc XP we heard
Marvel Studios is President Kevin Feige
talk about the future of the MCU as well
as show us some footage of the Eternals
and Black Widow and as it turns out
phase 4 may not exactly be what you
think it's going to be it's going to
have some major components to it that
are going to affect not only just phase
4 and phase 5 of the MCU but the
entirety of the MCU moving forward after
CC XP Kevin Feige sat down to do an
interview and talked about the one thing
that is going to change the MCU from
here on out moving forward and that one
thing is the multiverse that's right
Kevin Feige has officially confirmed the
multiverse although we knew it was
coming after all we are getting Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness it
was never confirmed and we were worried
that this could be sort of a spider-man
far from home type of thing where
Mysterio talks about the multiverse but
it doesn't really exist but luckily for
us Kevin Feige has specifically said the
multiverse is the future of the MCU
here's what he had to say at cc XP in
his interview immediately following his
Marvel panel when we first started the
MCU it was all about tony stark
introduced the world to tony stark and
that iron man armor then we went on to
teach people what Asgardians were and
learn about super soldiers and then
bring them together in Avengers I've
always loved space movies and I've
always loved big intergalactic tales
which is why we did guardians and the
audience came with us so we could do a
movie like in-game I always wanted to do
time travel which we finally got to do
an in-game the multiverse is the next
step in the evolution of the MCU and
Doctor Strange and the multiverse of
madness is going to crack it open in
ways that will have repercussions for a
Disney Plus series before it that's not
one division and four movies after it in
a big fun way so there you have it
straight from Kevin Feige himself the
multiverse is the future of the MCU it's
the key to the next step of evolution
for the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
according to him it's going to happen
before we get into Doctor Strange and
the multiverse of madness now we already
know that three Marvel projects are
going to tie together Doctor Strange and
the multiverse of madness Wan division
and Loki now what's really interesting
about what Kevin Feige said is that it's
going to tie into series that take place
before Doctor Strange and the multiverse
of
madness that are not one division now
it's already confirmed that one division
will deal with the multiverse but that
means there's a show or a movie before
one division that is going to introduce
the multiverse as well and if you narrow
it down there are really only two
options the Eternals and shang-chi and
between the two it's more than likely
going to be the Eternals and this
actually makes a lot of sense if we
think about it because Kevin Feige said
that the multiverse is going to be the
evolution of the MCU
well the Eternals are kind of about
evolution they are super humans created
by the celestial gods in fact they are
almost gods themselves they live for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years so more than likely they've come
across the multiverse at some point in
time but the Eternals is going to be
more of a overall connection of the
multiverse to phase 4 and phase 5 of the
MCU whereas one division dr. strange and
the multiverse of madness and Loki are
going to directly tie into one another
right now it's pretty much all but
confirmed that the reality that Wanda
and vision are going to be living in in
the series is going to be in a different
reality and this reality vision is going
to be alive she's going to have kids and
perhaps even her brother Quicksilver is
going to be alive as well and Kevin
Feige has already confirmed that Wanda
vision will directly connect to Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness and
Wanda is even going to be in the movie
and then of course in Doctor Strange
she's going to be dealing with the
multiverse that's what the movie is
going to be all about and he's probably
going to have to deal with some
alternate realities that were created in
Avengers endgame and that's probably how
the Loki series is going to connect to
Doctor Strange as well when Loki escaped
with the tesseract he created his own
timeline and his own different alternate
reality and Doctor Strange could perhaps
be trying to catch Loki and close this
alternate reality so they're all going
to connect together but the biggest
thing about the multiverse coming to the
MCU is now we can have things like
multiple spider-man multiple versions of
Doctor Strange we could even see
different versions of Iron Man of
Captain America of Thor they could all
return not truly playing themselves but
playing the alternate reality versions
of the character but by far the biggest
thing that this seems to be leading to
is battle world this will most likely be
the next Avengers in-game level type of
event we probably won't see it for
another
ten years but the bottle world event is
all of the multi versus colliding so now
that Kevin Feige has confirmed that the
multiverse is the future of the MCU
we could probably expect it all to lead
up to Avengers secret Wars battle world
and not to mention with Spider Man this
could also be the way to bring venom
into the MCU and to bring spider-man
into the venom Burres so a lot of
exciting things come with the
announcement of the multiverse so there
you have it the future of the MCU is the
multiverse coming from the president of
Marvel Studios himself Kevin Feige be
sure to let me know how excited you are
about this news and the comments down
below and also don't forget to subscribe
with the notifications turned on and
leave a like on this video so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 don't forget to use
code cosmic at G fuel comm for 30% off
until December 25th and as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof